[Music]
what will be his excuse for lying about
a noose
the trial of hate crime hoaxer jesse
smallette kicked off today you'll recall
roughly three years ago jesse is alleged
to have orchestrated an elaborate hate
crime against himself one in which he's
accused of paying friends to stage a
racist attack involving nooses bleach
and maga hats what's known as the cnn
gift pack
so will he testify in his own defense
which could make or break the case
attorney mark
can never say his name
did i nail it told fox news quote he's
an actor so he has an advantage over
almost anyone who is going to take the
witness stand
and that is the best review he's ever
gotten about his acting
but let's not forget his democrat
supporters including our vp who tweeted
in 2019 jesse smallett is one of the
kindest most gentle human beings i know
i'm praying for his quick recovery this
was an attempted modern day lynching no
one should have to fear for their life
because of their sexuality or color of
their skin we must confront this hate
so we're just gonna leave that tweet
there to remind you how stupid she
really is
i think we've
i think we've forgotten
yeah
for more let's go to our legal
correspondent owl roker owl what's your
prediction for the trial
[Music]
that's
the number one cable network in the
world ladies and gentlemen all right
tyrus um where do you see this going
well first of all it's juicy soir
yes
um i think this
you know
first of all i'm surprised he's also not
being charged with uh hate crime as well
because his use of nigerians playing to
that thing where they're all tricksters
and trying to get you out of money and
stuff that was not fair you know you
picked those two innocent young
bodybuilders guys
yeah i mean incredible
asking body builders to attack you in
freezing cold weather
there's a lot of warm-ups involved there
it takes you know
but the the fact that his lawyer's
saying
he's an actor he's gonna do fine
the jury knows that too and i'm sure
besides the
overwhelming evidence against him
what could he possibly say on the stand
that could sway anyone at this point he
only needs one juror though and one
juror who's a fan of his right that's
all he needs yeah i mean he's got to
have one fan somewhere he's he pretty
much
pissed off every box of every person
every group that ran to his aid there
and when it came out they're like wow
and he left every box checked yeah
that's in terms of who's alienating
stuff so i personally won't watch any of
this because this is a slam dunk case
but it's on a tv yeah just for him to
try to somehow connect this to poor
parenting or or pressure or the man yeah
or maybe it'll be another attack right
before he gets on the stand like who
knows you know like oh my you know two
swedish interns just jumped him outside
of the oh
i can dream
cat um
he has a bit it's like two and a half
years and he hasn't like if i were
innocent for two and a half years i'd be
running around screaming i'm innocent
i'd be all over the place but you would
i wouldn't be all over the place you
stay home but
that's true a lot of scathing emails
yeah i would send a lot of scathing
emails
generally from the bed it would be i i
don't know it's so easy i could lawyer
him to jail yes yeah just ask him
what do you get at subway
oh that's a great question right that's
what colombo would do yeah because
because
if you are at st if you were leaving in
chicago at 2 a.m and like freezing
temperatures to go to subway you don't
just like subway you love subway more
than anyone
ever
you have an order yes that he does it
yeah but he does this is so colombo of
you
this is so colomba and you almost have
his voice
yeah almost
just a few more vacations
mine's a little deeper
well i'm a big fan josie smiletta my
wife's a big fan of yours i was
wondering if i could get you to sign
this picture of you ah that's the same
signature
on the guy who bought the noose
that's how it would go
that's how it would go joe it could go
like that but first off i think this
lawyer is overconfident but this lawyer
that's not his lawyer that was just a
lawyer commenting well he's
overconfident because uh seth rogen just
proved actors when they write their own
lines kind of screw up a lot
but i i uh
i think that the jury has a chance to be
impartial on this one i think that
they're gonna find him they're probably
gonna find him guilty because
uh
there's there's two things i worry about
in a trial it's whether or not the
prosecutes
prosecution's gonna play fair which we
we found out in the written house case
doesn't always happen and two can the
defendant afford a good lawyer and if he
can write
a 3 500 check for people to fake beat
him up
he's going to have a good lawyer
and i don't even think he ever paid
those guys oh i thought he wrote like a
b no he didn't pay them and subway was
their bad too because that's where you
can get the protein meal without the
bread
you probably can't even go back to
subway now those poor guys guy you know
it's i i i'm saying this i already said
it i'm mad this isn't on tv i would
watch this i would watch the hell out of
this
because he does have the advantage of
being an actor he has the disadvantage
of being very dumb yeah right so they
might
balance out and i call him very dumb not
because i know him but because i have
seen the hate crime that he tried to
organize right and it is hilarious i
hope he gets uh what he deserves and the
people of chicago get justice because it
was just outrageous what happened here
but i am delighted that we get to talk
about this more because it's one of my
favorite news stories ever yes this guy
everything he did was hilariously dumb
and wrong exactly did write a personal
check
like did he write hate crime on the memo
it's like oh it's for the hate crime
here you go
like what was this man thinking yes he
kept the noose yeah on him apparently
the noose was also underneath his collar
like it was a like a loosened tie
it's a it's just like chef's kiss
everything about this i wish it were
televised i would watch i know i know he
could have just said this happened he
didn't have to provide all the evidence
yes